a Republican presidential candidate
that's kind of sort of maybe okay let's
talk about a social issue gay marriage
in New Hampshire you said I will fight
for your right to be left alone I
realized that you believe gay marriage
is a state issue but why do you believe
just as a core principle as a
libertarian that people should be left
alone but not when it comes to their
right to marry somebody they love I do
believe people ought to be left alone I
don't care who you are what you do at
home or who your friends are what you
know where you hang out what kind of
music you listen to what you do in your
home's your own business that's always
been who I am I am a leave me alone kind
of guy but not when it comes to marriage
well no I mean state states will end up
making the decisions on these things I
think that there's a religious
connotation to marriage I believe in the
traditional religious connotation to
this but I also believe people ought to
be treated fairly under the law I see no
reason why if the marriage contract
conveys certain things that if if you if
you want to marry another woman you can
do that and have a contract but the
thing is is the religious connotation of
marriage that has been going on for
thousands of years I still want to
preserve that and you probably could
have both you could have both
traditional marriage which I believe in
and then you could also have the
neutrality of the law that allows people
to have contracts with another all right
I know I'm gonna get a lot of [ __ ] for
this but I basically think that's okay
he's saying gay people should have the
exact same rights but the word marriage
has a really just kind of tation it's
not that I agree with the principle and
I don't believe in separate but equal
but for a Republican that's trying to
win with the right wing nuts of his
party to win a nomination he's basically
saying I don't care about the gay issue
let's not make it an issue for 2016 I
don't think he's fighting against gay
people I get it I know what everyone's
gonna say on this I'm gonna go to you
first because I saw that face during the
video I mean I just I don't like it even
watching that made me cringe a little
bit cuz it's slimy I get it it's slimy
right he's playing politics but I know
that
saying that you know it'll help him win
on the Republican ticket but he's
already said so many things that have
kind of screwed his chances for that
anyways I mean he's very for legalizing
drugs and he's against military
industrial complex overusing it and
things like that that I like about his
you like I like to employ but I mean
that kind of screws him on the right but
as far as this it's just it is separate
but equal and it's horrible and he keeps
going on and on about how it's got this
religious connotation which is total
[ __ ] [ __ ] because marriage is
going on way before religion came and
stolid they don't have a copyright on it
they haven't patent it it's something
that everyone should be able to have and
I think a lot of people who are gay who
get married are actually still religious
I'm gay and going to get married so if I
say this with all due eye are you still
like yeah if there's freedom of religion
and there should be freedom of religion
with people who are gay who want to get
married in a church if they want if it's
a church that's willing and they want to
have it and they think that that's
traditional marriage and that's what it
means to them then why not why well I
don't think he's saying that they
wouldn't be allowed to get married in a
church if the church allowed it I think
he's just saying he didn't saying the
word and then him gay people just right
yeah the only reason I'm ok with this is
just cuz I know how nutty the the right
side of his party is and he's trying to
so because he's not trying to make gay
an issue he knows that it's done he's a
libertarian he doesn't want to be in
your bedroom so actually he should be
totally forget he should be totally for
weed which is not totally for her that's
and that's another topic but like to me
that seems like this is progress like
this is progress come on give me
something here yeah I have a historical
difficulty with any concept of separate
but equal yeah any concept of it not
really I don't know if it's maybe the
color of my skin a little uncomfortable
with that concept in general yeah and
the last time any woman in my family was
in a relationship with a man or with
anybody a woman that there was a
contract it was a slave yeah so really
not not down with that terminology
either so just you know why politics is
so [ __ ] up like I'm trying to be like
pragmatic here and being like oh I get
what he has to do politically to do this
but the principle is ok but doesn't that
doesn't this whole thing then feel slimy
because then it's like look if he
doesn't get the support then it could be
a guy like Ted Cruz who would gladly get
rid of gay marriage of the entire gops
discriminated the discrimination against
LGBT people against women and I really
hope that the left uses that against
them in the upcoming election yeah I
mean it's been 50 years since the civil
rights era and there are still people
out there who think that discrimination
is okay yeah it's like if you can't
grasp the simple concept that hey gay
people are normal equal individuals if
you can't understand that
then I don't really think that you can
really give much insight into more
complicated issues it's like hey they
think discrimination is cool now let's
see what they have to say on
macroeconomic well exactly because also
if it doesn't there's no logical stand
on it they don't you know when they
always say well it'll ruin the family
except we keep getting gay marriage in
more and more states
have you noticed any families crumbling
actually I've seen families get stronger
you see the couple married another guy
and that seed that could have been a
family he ruined it he ruined that
non-existent family has your family been
ruined like Shauna's by gays these
activist gays let us know what you think
in the comments right now